alright just a quick summary of of the
solving so the theory of solving the
general pubic involves that substitution
x equals y minus one-third a it leads to
this equation the depressed cubic where
a equals that and B equals that I
haven't seen these yet whether they come
from well they come from this and the
enormous amount of algebra the results
and condensing down anak weighting
coefficients again those we did it
numerically remember we did it for a
numerical example we came up with our
values of a and bit if you are keeping
everything general then you get these
the article has the details the theory
of solving the depressed cube involves
this substitution wipers you plus B so
I'm just writing in terms of Y here for
citizen context why does he possibility
deriving two simultaneous equations
deriving a quadratic combining the two
solutions with a quadratic to get here
rapid example
use our run sheet right if you kind of
self 20 in a row you'd want to have that
in front of it and of course we have to
work backwards we have to build the
building blocks and get to be so if this
is the idea of this rapid example is not
to you know see what the solution is but
to see if you were doing this a lot how
much work would be involved in each one
so there's you a substitution there's
you be substitution there's your Delta
as you why no complex numbers this time
so that now always complex right that's
why to discriminate it looked to see
whether that thing is negative or
positive to find out all right and so
obviously a bit of calculator workers
they're required there but and they are
to our solutions have not a nice
solution that's a randomly chosen
equation and then the x equals y minus
of third a so we get that is our
solution to that all right and I don't
know what the other two solutions are